je me suis dit comment est ce que je
vais commencer cette vidéo est ce que je
vais commencer par ou samsung galaxy s
22e le test c'est ça ouais ça me
paraissait pas mal mais je me suis dit
qu'il fallait beaucoup plus loin et moi
y'a un truc et j'ai vachement et mais
c'est ça ce smartphone est très premium
voilà c'est absolument ridicule de vous
dire ça je sais c'est très convenue mais
c'est la réalité ce smartphone est
extrêmement très près même on se parle
aujourd'hui du samsung galaxy s 22 plus
on va le regarder le décortiquer la
photo la vidéo l'expérience la puissance
la performance en va tout regarder je
vais vous dire au final si ce samsung
galaxy s 22 plus c'est intéressant et
s'il faut se positionner oui ou non
allez on y va
[Musique]
le premier truc que j'ai aimé c'est
vraiment lorsque je les ai pris en main
et ça se confirme de jour en jour à
chaque fois que le programme parce que
des smartphones j'apprends beaucoup en
main j'en ai à droite à gauche la bonne
image en noir 4,5 à côté je t'ai ce
jeudi qu'ooyala qui sont sortis de là
qui ne sont pas encore sorties donc
autant vos dix achètent quand même usé
et celui là il ya un truc que je trouve
vachement bien c'est ce côté déjà un peu
bombé sur le côté en termes de prise en
main qui apporte pas un petit confort en
plus lorsqu'on vient de saisir comme ça
directement dans sa main on le sent et
tout de suite très très très confortable
on a vraiment ce côté extrêmement
premium et on le ressent vraiment à
chaque fois qu'on va le prendre en main
et à chaque fois qu'on le sang saisies
on se dit il et premium il est beau et
je puis vous assurer que c'est un truc
qui peut paraît tout bête mais cette
sensation elle est là et elle revient à
chaque fois déjà il est beau il est
esthétique la voulait c'est absolument
aucune trace de doigt dans une couleur
rose là mais je trouve très sympa aussi
comme ça avec ce petit module photo qui
est légèrement biseautés sur le côté
alors ça peut paraître une fois de plus
un petit peu de points de détails mais
il ya un côté vraiment qui vient
rajouter au premium le biseau tu es là
le biseautés que vous avez à l'intérieur
également ici donc si tous ces petits
détails qui font qu'on se dit que ce
smartphone il est quand même vachement
classe vraiment que vous soyez sur la
face avant que vous soyez sur la face
arrière après il ya un autre gros
travail qui a fait samsung ici c'est de
faire attention à vraiment vous proposer
une expérience avec une symétrie
parfaite pour que vous n'ayez pas de
petits manteaux en bas ce qui fait que
vous avez vraiment une symétrie vraiment
entre le petit cadre que vous avez à
l'extérieur entre les bords que vous
avez tout autour ça peut paraître tout
bête mais je puis vous assurer que pour
réussir à passer toutes les connectiques
une bonne manière mais c'est déjà
quelque chose qui coûte cher parce qu'il
a fallu du développement et ça vous
donne un résultat qui esthétiquement
super beau et super bien aboutie donc
c'est vraiment peut-être du point de
détail pour vous mais pour moi ça veut
dire beaucoup et j'aime bien l'idée très
très beau travail donc ça c'est le
premier point extrêmement positif très
belle finition premium
niveau de ce smartphone voilà mes et ça
je vous le dis et je vous le redis à
chaque fois c'est un smartphone qui
malgré tout même si les protégés même si
il est beau même si on a des matériaux
de bonne qualité il faut venir le
protéger pour éviter les déconvenues si
jamais vous le faites tomber ça peut
arriver mais pour nous la protégeons
fait quoi et bien on prend une coque ou
une protection d'écran de mon partenaire
rhino shields alors qu'aujourd'hui vidéo
qui a réalisé en partenariat avec rideau
chine alors je vous le montre regarder
chez rhinochill vous en avez plein plein
de produits et on va y aller france
billet vous avez 5 % de remise avec le
code grevin de grr 22 5% de remise sur
tous vos achats et vous avez les s 22
qui sont là ça c'est plutôt la bonne
nouvelle alors les produits vont arriver
directement ici vous allez voir
attendant je vais vous montrer ce que
vous pouvez avoir vous avez bien
évidemment chez rhinochill des biens des
coques des solides suite qu'on peut
venir personnalisé je vais vous montrer
ça mais vous avez également des
protections d'écran parce qu'il faut
venir protéger la face avant de votre
smartphone parce que si vous le faites
tomber up lavialle à toi si vous le
faites tomber et qu' il se prend un
mauvais choc à l'avant nouveau shoot
shoot shoot shoot bref s'il tombe et là
ça me protège ça c'est cool et vous avez
également des câbles des accessoires
dispose sur le store de rhinau chi
d'avoir des jumeaux parce que tout est
très chouette et je montre à chaque fois
parce que j'adore vraiment c'est ce
qu'on va appeler les collaborations va
avoir des coqs qui vont être très
différent de tout ce qu'on peut me
retrouver sur le marché va avoir
notamment du spider man allez on y va un
peu au pif comme ça je monte le kit si
la nba pop corn friends si vous avez
raison tous les avoirs également on en a
énormément hinan que j'ai le dos je ne
connais pas les noms alors mayereau
cannes amiens je connais payet mais ça
fait remarquer beaucoup de monde je suis
désolé vinet carmine et quand je
connaissais pas hunter enter ok fortes
têtes assassin's creed squeeze également
vilebrequin à isle of doodle qu'on va
retrouver également fairy tail più di pa
i gotta cas vitality unicorn des côtes
et des zooms c'est voilà donc y en a de
tous les côtés je vous laisse jeter un
petit coup d'oeil directement par vous
même des collabos il y en a plein plein
plein et c'est ça qu'on aime et qui est
très très chouette et on va retrouver
pour moi les petits coups de coeur qui
sont vraiment ici y avoir tout star wars
va y avoir tout marvel va y avoir bras
good boy ainsi dragon ball z vous avez
du pixar du harry potter les tags des
titans donc tout ça c'est chouette et y
en a énormément donc à tous les coups
vous avez trouvé votre bonheur une fois
de plus le lien est en bas dans la
description code greu 22 pour me
retrouver ce qui vous conviendra et si
vous êtes fan de batman parce qu'à
batman qui va sortir elle m'a regardé
vous avez plein de batman et ça c'est
plutôt la très très très bonne nouvelle
à gotham city on y va comme ça et après
ils sortent de nouveaux produits alors
c'est pas temps aujourd'hui ses nouveaux
produits pour les samsung galaxy s 22
c'est plus pour les iphone ce sont les
coques qu'on appelle clear mais ça on en
reparlera une prochaine fois voilà je
vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description autre point qui est
extrêmement important qui me plaît
énormément c'est cette dalle alors on
s'en rend pas forcément compte au
travers d'une caméra comme ça mais c'est
du dainik amoled 2 x on va reprendre
très rapidement l'histoire samsung
maîtrise et dalles dans le fameux son
groupe vous avez sam sont display qui
fabrique des écrans qui fabrique des
dalles et là c'est la dynamique amoled 2
x qui est vraiment extrêmement bien
calibré c'est peut-être l'expérience
ultime aujourd'hui c'est ça me saoule
pour avoir cette dalle là et elle marche
tellement bien tellement belle très très
grosse luminosité vous pouvez l'emmener
en extérieur absolument eu aucun
problème là il fait très beau vous le
voyez pas vous le verrez dans les vidéos
se faire le test vidéo dans quelques
instants il ya aucun problème ça ça
marche très très bien en plus de ça vous
avez de la fluidité des mouvements vous
de 10h à 120 hertz élus adaptative donc
ça c'est aussi très très bien pour toute
l'expérience en termes de fluidité
lorsque vous allez venir jouer et
lorsque vous allez venir se coller sur
vos réseaux sociaux et lorsque vous
l'utilisez pas eh bien ça fonctionnera
également donc on a un truc qui est
vachement cool plein d'options très très
belle dalle très très bien calibrée donc
ça c'est le point positif point positif
est bien c'est que pour venir regarder
des films des séries comme vous avez ce
côté là voyez avec une vraie symétrie ça
fonctionne alors on regrettera
probablement qu on est toujours ce petit
point sont on attend effectivement la
caméra sous l'écran on l'a déjà vu avec
le z folle de 3 c'était pas mal mais pas
parfait je pense que seront gamess quand
ils intégreront ce sera parfait et on le
verra plus et on aura pour autant de
très très belles photos ce n'était pas
le cas sur z folle de 3 qu'une caméra si
je me trompe pas de 5 mégapixels cinq
mois c'est ça c'était pas fou mais bon
c'est déjà bien donc c'était déjà un
beau pas en avant donc on attend la
techno arrive probablement on espère sur
les aces 23 les prochaines on croise les
doigts en attendant c'est chouette voilà
donc très très belle dalle extrêmement
bien calibré donc pour l'expérience de
visionnage de films de séries vous avez
ce qu'il faut sous la garde et netflix
youtube et compagnie pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés l'expérience audio aussi est
très courageux vous fait écouter je vous
mets mon test du s22 ultra regarder hop
là on va avancer un peu qu'on va se
mettre sa faune
donc là vous et votre parlant de
renforts qui a un peu de grave et ça qui
est intéressant c'est très différent des
autres smartphones dans cette gamme de
prix
on va venir saturé légèrement lorsque je
le pousse à fond mais c'est pas le but
et là ça conviendra alors c'est vrai que
c'est pas forcément le smartphone vous
allez avoir le plus de sons et ça va
envoyer le maximum de purée mais le
spectre est plutôt bien vous avez des
graves et ça conviendra si vous voulez
acheter ce smartphone tout de suite au
moment de son lancement vous avez des
galaxies bugs profère ça serait vraiment
dommage de venir sont privées parce
qu'ils coûtent de mémoire petite remise
et ses 5 579 euros heure vous ai fait
une vidéo pourra découvrir les galaxies
bug savoir lequel acheter aller voir les
bugs pro parce qu'ils sont offerts ce
serait vraiment une fois de plus dommage
de venir vous en passez d'ailleurs le
lien dans la description si vous voulez
le pré commander sur le site de samsung
après il ya un autre truc à savoir c'est
que cette année vous n'avez pas de petit
casque filaire fourni avec en usb c'est
ça peut être un peu dommage ça peut
venir faire allez donc si vous n'avez
pas des buzz bon peut-être le moment d'y
aller il ya notre que j'aime beaucoup et
que samsung a fait c'est de venir
augmenter la vitesse de charge on passe
d'un bloc de 25 watts l'année dernière
sur les modèles plus un bloc de 40 50
ans une vitesse de 45 watts alors pour
autant le bloc de charges n'est pas
inclus est ailleurs il faut bien
l'acheter en plus sur le store de
samsung ou alors sur des vendeurs qui
ont des blogs compatibles les vrais bons
vendeurs avec des blocs compatibles on
ne parle pas d'un truc un peu pourri
pourri à droite à gauche ce que je vous
conseille fois de plus c'est de venir
acheter les accessoires compatibles
directement sur le site de sam sont
comme ça il y aura pas de mauvaises
surprises 45 watts ça va charger
beaucoup plus vite aujourd'hui mois à
venir se poser la question de
l'autonomie alors l'autonomie elle est
importante parce que si vous utilisez
beaucoup votre smartphone vous voulez
qui durent dans le temps mais ce qui est
important c'est le temps de recharge qui
va améliorer significativement
l'expérience il est loin le temps où on
avait dû 5 watts où on était deshors
avenir recharger son smartphone avec du
45 watts vous aller tranquille donc même
si vous êtes un hardcore gamer sur
smartphone et que vous jouez beaucoup et
bien vous allez pouvoir à un moment où
dire ben voilà j'en sais rien je tiens
pas la journée parce que j'y suis allé
un peu fort vous prenez vous le branchez
un petit quart d'heure et vous êtes
reparti pour un jour donc ça c'est cool
et ça c'est rassurant donc bien vous une
batterie quatre mille cinq cents
millions père à l'intérieur grâce aux 45
watts même si vous la vivez vous la
branchez vous êtes tranquille donc ça
c'est vachement cool il ya un autre truc
qui est vraiment extrêmement important
ici c'est toute l'expérience logiciel
avec when you lie alors je vous l'avais
déjà montré je vous ai fait une vidéo
survenu à 4 là c'est la 4.0 vous allez
retrouver ici et où annuel cattrall est
vachement bien pourquoi parce que déjà
on a beaucoup de visibilité on y
regroupées par thématiques vous avez
toutes les questions données
biométriques fin bref je vous laisse
aller voir ma vidéo comme ça vous serez
tous et vous découvrirez en profondeur
when you're my way you lie en fait ce
que ça veut dire faire estime au niveau
du 4 ça vient reprendre toute la partie
personnalisation on appellera matériel
you d'android 12 que vous allez
retrouver ici dans votre fond d'écran et
dans ce style vous pouvez venir modifier
vous avez une palette de couleurs
regardez où vous dites 21 je veux que ça
ressemble à quoi aujourd'hui au music
hall sur mon smartphone matériel des
couleurs que j'aime bien je peux venir
complètement personnalisé je peux
également l'appliquer aux icônes donc ça
vous donne un rendu qui est vachement
sympa bonnière personnalisé customiser
toute l'expérience ici donc ça c'est
vachement cool c'est ou annuels 4.1 basé
sur android 12 et puis vous avez tout ce
qui est extrêmement important qui cite
l'arrière c'est la partie photo vidéo
alors qu'il est déjà présentée peu fait
très rapidement lors de ma vidéo de
présentation de ce smartphone je vous
mets le lien quelque part par ici vous
irez voir en fait vous avez un capteur
principal 50 méga pixels c'est un
autofocus duel pixels donc lui permettra
d'avoir un meilleur autofocus pour plus
grosses lettres t stabilisation optique
nous ouvrait à f 1.8 et puis surtout le
fait d'avoir 50 méga pixels ça vous
permet de regrouper plusieurs pixels et
mai en un seul et même pixels notamment
pour les photos de nuit vous allez voir
résultats dans quelques instants vous
avez un ultra grand temps de 12
mégapixels on passe très très rapidement
puis vous avez un téléobjectif 10
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 3 et
une caméra de celle fille de 10
mégapixels qui a planqué à l'avant il
vous allez voir que ici c'est pas là on
va avoir la meilleure expérience mais on
s'en doutera je vous demande des photos
que j'ai prises avec mon samsung galaxy
s 22 plus et vous allez voir que il est
très beau en photos vraiment très très
bon on ira moins loin qu'avec les ultras
mais ce qu'on fait on le fait vachement
bien regarder en grand angle ultra grand
temps d'ailleurs un truc qui est super
bien c'est que la colorimétrie est la
même on n'a pas de là on n'a pas de très
grosse différence entre les deux grands
dans l'ultra grand temps ultra
grand-angle est pas nécessairement des
formes en a forcément sur les côtés
c'est de l'article on dirait qu'on
perdra légèrement en précision mais dans
l'ensemble c'est vachement bien et ça
fonctionne très très bien on vient où
met on vient se rapprocher n'oublions
pas qu'on l'ait sur un foie trois
optiques serra très très bien on peut
venir accrocher mais comme tout je
dirais que plus on va preez - en aura
mais dans l'ensemble c'est vachement
bien la gestion des contre-jours la
gestion des hautes lumières est très
très bonne vous avez le belvédère vous
avez bien tous les détails du belvédère
vous avez bien les arbres sur le devant
vous avez bien le ciel rien et cramer
vous avez tous les nuages il ya une
super bonne gestion de notre lumière
très bonne gestion de la plage dynamique
c'est un peu moins bon sur l'ultra grand
temps et on le voit la voyait sur des
parties sur le bas ici on vient se
perdre un peu c'est un peu moins bon
mais dans l'ensemble sortir quand même
de très jolies choses on vient nous met
un peu c'est un très très bien on peut
bien se rapprocher voire les
cochonneries directement dans le
belvédère si on veut mais au-delà de ce
travail est là c'est pareil sur notre
dame ce que j'apprécie c'est que tous
les nuages ici ne sont pas cramé on a
bien tout on a effectivement les gens
devant retrouve tous donc dans
l'ensemble c'est un très très très jolie
photophone et vous allez le voir alors
voyez quand on vient nous met davantage
il a un peu plus de mal mais dans
l'ensemble lors pas au niveau de la
qualité du zuma mais au niveau de la
gestion des lumières parce qu'ici à côté
hugo rythmique il est pas tout vous
corriger mais dans l'ensemble on va
quand même et c'est plutôt pas mal donc
j'aime bien le travail qui a été fait
ici par samsung samsung en général au
niveau de la photo est très bon même
radio haut niveau notre dame luttera
grand-angle et très bons donc voilà je
vais passer mon temps à vous dire que
c'est très bon qu'il faut pas venir trop
zoomer mais ce que je vous dis pourtant
c'est exactement ça même là lorsque vous
avez le soleil qui est juste là voyez on
voit bien là on a bien les détails on
les nuages à côté on a bien les façades
voilà c'est dans l'ensemble vraiment
bien bossé je dois reconnaître que
c'est un très très jolies photos je vous
dis voilà on vient de nommer en x 3 en
faut dix on va pas plus loin mais dans
l'ensemble ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
bien garder là c'est pareil là au niveau
du panthéon résultat est vraiment
magnifique avec un soleil sur le côté
sur l' ultra grand angle pour autant
c'est très très bon donc voilà je vous
montre les photos mais regardez là je
suis en x 3 l'âge dans la qualité du x 3
je trouve superbe l'oncfs à trois
optiques on a vraiment tous les détails
qu'on veut on vient se rapprocher la
voyais on en numérique mais malgré tout
il ya très léger lissage mais le boulot
est fait et bien fait dans la caméra de
celle fille elle fonctionne pas trop mal
je suis un peu moins fan de la caméra de
celle fils n'est pas extrêmement où il
faut beaucoup de lumière on a un capteur
qui va être un peu plus petits surtout
au niveau de lentilles ça va moins de ça
mais dans l'ensemble le boulot quand
même pas trop mal fait ça reste pas mal
regardé je vous montre un pur moment
pour vous avez des idées lorsqu'on vient
ou mais davantage aux salissent c'est
pas beau mais sinon sens des choses bien
leur même la photo de nuit est vraiment
bien alors sans le capteur principal
attention parce que si vous passez sur
l'ultra grand temps que ça doit sentir
beaucoup plus brouillon il sera beaucoup
moins gérer ce genre de chose pareil
lorsque vous venez zoomer je suis pas
extrêmement convaincu vrai sur votre
capteur principal tels que là vous avez
une super à gestion de la lumière un peu
moins bonne que sur le ultra que je
trouvais meilleur après vous avez aussi
un plus gros capteurs sur l'ultra 200 8
mégapixels qui sera bien meilleure mais
on fait quand même des choses qui sont
vachement bien ici alors hop on passe
l'ultra grand temps de regarder la
laissant le grand temps que c'est bien
c'est vraiment la différence avec les
ultras c'est la gestion de ces lumières
là qui sera un peu moins bonne sur les
ultras halle sera quand même meilleur
vous invite à lire ma vidéo avec les
premières photos prises avec l'ultra
caméra de celle ci la nuit très
clairement le boulot très très mal faits
ces brutes et c'est pas beau il n'y
arrive pas voilà c'est vraiment le ce
que je veux dire lui reprocher mais
sinon sur le capteur principal on sort
des choses qui sont très très très très
joli sur ce smartphone gardella capteur
principal capteur principal on a même
ici les petites toiles d'araignées c'est
dire donc c'est plutôt bien s'est plutôt
bien si on veut vraiment ce qui se fait
de mieux en terme de photos de nuit
aujourd'hui chez samsung on va sur les
ultras mais sinon avec le f 22 et le s20
de plus vous aurez de très jolis
résultats puisque ce sont exactement les
mêmes configurations les mêmes capteurs
en termes de photos et en terme de vidéo
bonsoir ou de vidéos là avec le f 22
vous les faits l'autre jour avec le f-22
ultra longtemps quand on fait de la
jouerons serait une nuit on s'est
toujours on se fait la nuit c'est plutôt
ça regardez la chaux montre que ça
raconte avec la vidéo de nuit alors on
est en ville il ya quand même des leçons
de lumière comme ça vous voyez un petit
peu ce que ça peut donner donc là sur le
capteur principal et maintenant on va
passer sur l'ultra garantie alors
forcément les soutras longtemps ils ont
besoin de plus de lumière pour être
nourri donc à nu c'est pas terrible en
photo c'est pas aux filiales et
évidemment en vidéo n'aura pas de magie
non plus alors on vous le propose en
devenir zoom et envoyait la cdu x 3 je
peux bien faire beaucoup plus le déjà x
3 comme ça c'est pas ouf donc 6e
rapprocher si je fais plus j'ai bien
peur que le résultat soit pas mieux donc
on va se contenter ici uniquement du
foin et ce sera largement suffisant j'ai
aussi est ma carrière at il dit ça sera
pas la meilleure je le vois c'est pas la
meilleure mais bon c'est toujours cette
prime cette caméra cette étude servira
vraiment le jour parce que pour moi la
nuit elle et elle n'est pas parfaite
elle est pas terrible donc on retient
ici que convenir faire de la vidéo de
nuit on fait quoi on utilise son capteur
principal à l'arrière c'est tout et
c'est déjà très très bien donc là je
vais filmer avec mon capteur principal à
l'arrière la caméra principale à
l'arrière mon grand angle à l'arrière on
peut venir faire des choses plutôt pas
mal c'est d'ailleurs ce sera le meilleur
en termes de qualité s'ils voulaient
venir filmer comme ça car dès que vous
ayez beaucoup de lumière ou pas
énormément il y en a beaucoup
aujourd'hui les choix éthiques mais dans
une zone un peu plus donc pour vous le
montrez on peut venir filmer avec votre
grand angle à ultra grand angle au
téléobjectif ici ce qui va être vraiment
intéressant ces grands noms et les
autres à être un peu tard encore
qui va ici pas y trouve ça va être le
micro parce que c'est un peu le parent
pauvre c'est pas là vont avoir la
meilleure qualité si on veut optimiser
avant la meilleure qualité au niveau du
micro ce que je vous recommande c'est de
venir sauf un petit micro est stable que
vous venez marcher dessus par exemple
j'utilise un petit pied de joby vous
pouvez vous pouvez venir brancher un
petit micro externe avec un petit câble
dédié samsung en usb c'est avec une
prise jack de l'autre côté femelles et
bien vous pouvez venir brancher un petit
micro on pourra voir une source externe
ça sera ce qu'elle mieux alors on peut
venir faire les choses comme ça pour
venir shooter de l'image ça ira très
bien combien ferrera peu de bloguer mais
faut pas qu'ils aient trop de bruit
sinon à une vraie déperdition au niveau
audio il ya aussi un truc qui existe et
lorsque vous venez zoomer avec votre
télé objectif vous allez pouvoir venir
avoir un zoom audio au niveau du micro
c'est pas ouf mais on peut le faire et
c'est pourquoi pas assez marrant assez
intéressant à vous de voir ça peut vous
intéresser ce que je voudrais qu'on y
est ce vraiment si vous êtes en mode
blogging s'était approché un petit micro
sur le dessus mais voyant pas venir
choper de l'image comme ça alors ça peut
être de l'image additionnel vidal
utiliser tout le temps source principale
c'est pas là on aura la meilleure
qualité ça peut être pas mal à voir on
peut faire des images mais bon voilà
nous en tout cas assez marrant est plus
bas que samsung progresse tout temps sur
la joue le monde sur le grand-angle et
maintenant je vais passer sur l' ultra
grand-angle et si vous voulez venir
élargir l'horizon vous avez lu
ultra-grand-angle on peut venir se
rapprocher c'est tout un peu positif
avec l'ultra grand temps si vous pouvez
rapprocher le smartphone et venir capter
le son un peu plus proche voilà c'est
pas leur truc intéressant je vous
conseille quand même pour maximiser
l'expérience d'utiliser le grand temps
c'est là vous aurez le meilleur capteur
mais si vous voulez en prendre plus en
capter plus lui travaille en tant que si
une solution sans oublier la caméra
telle fille mais là c'est pas stabilisé
et voyez ça bouge alors moi je suis un
très mauvais client fashion très bon
crash test pour les marques ça bouge on
n'a aucune stade donc pour pas que ça
bouge je tiens à deux mains je le mets
sur un trépied de toute façon ici je
n'aurais pas le meilleur capteur dont
j'aurais pas la meilleure expérience aux
caméras de celle fille je la trouve pas
où je sois toujours un peu dommage à
s'ouvrir sur des smartphones très haut
de gamme les constructeurs n'arrive pas
à nous intégrer lors c'est probablement
lié à la question des espaces pour
pouvoir intégrer un un bon capteur et
des lentilles mais on a toujours un truc
un peu un peu pas terrible pour sachant
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de personnes
font du lobbying ce serait très bien
d'avoir une bonne caméra à l'avant ce
qui n'est pas le cas regardez voyez là
après ça c'est mon problème c'est moi
qui tremble mais passe en ski sur cette
rue capteur est ce qu'il est donc vous
troubliez ou pas
tesla manoir avec beaucoup de soleil je
serai en pleine tronche pas forcément il
faut de la lumière il peut venir nourrir
les capteurs dont avec le grand temps
que ça ira très bien et c'est ce qui
conviendra le mieux mais ça fait aussi
pas mal comme ça il ya s'intéressant des
plus 30 ans voilà et là je switche en
ultra grand-angle alors on va regarder
s'il venait à contre-jour forcément ça
va un peu moins bien le faire mais bon
voilà en tout cas on peut venir faire
des choses c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est de voir l'évolution de voir que
des marques comme samsung permettent
avec des smartphones très haut de gamme
attention pas vraiment du très haut de
gamme on est sur le heisman de plus ici
est bien de pouvoir avoir tout temps que
tout un chacun puisse avoir une petite
caméra à portée de main pour venir
filmer pendant la créativité est ce
qu'on peut venir faire un film avec pour
les réseaux oui pour le web ou y pour la
télé je ne suis pas convaincu à moins
qu'on ait vraiment avoir cette
expérience où on prend un smartphone et
où on va filmer directement comme ça je
trouve intéressant je pense qu'ils ont
bien bossé au niveau de la caméra donc
si vous voulez ici une petite caméra à
venir prendre à la main une caméra
additionnel un recueil sur lui on nous
rend meilleurs capteurs mais déjà comme
ça avec le f 22 et es22 puisque ce sont
exactement les mêmes capteurs qu'on a la
même capacité de calcul et connaît le
même processeur dans nos rangs déjà tout
ira très très bien donc si vous voulez
vous amuser être créatif en photos et en
vidéo 2 jour comme de nuit f 22 et f 22
pouces plutôt très bien
il ya un autre mode qui existe c'est le
mode de vidéo vidéo portrait le mode
vidéo portrait vous permet effectivement
et bien d'avoir du flou derrière parce
que c'est dû comme de la photo portrait
mais c'est du vidéo portrait est ce que
pour autant le vidéo portrait est
vachement bien je suis pas extrêmement
convaincu si vous mettez sur un flou qui
est très très léger ça devrait passer
mais si vous le poussez si vous le
montrer à fond ça concerne tout de suite
beaucoup magna s'est pas encore un peu
qui est vachement là et je trouve pas ça
vraiment efficace en fait ce qu'ils
veulent faire et cissé imité un peu
l'effet de bloquer qu'on va voir avec
des gros boîtier pour avoir un côté
esthétique avec le foot en arrière-plan
est ce que c'est ce que j'aime bien
attendre d'un smartphone aujourd'hui
j'en suis pas convaincu est ce que je
veux aller dessus je ne suis pas
convaincu et si je pousse le trait si je
le pousse à fond elle va c'est pas
extraordinaire alors ya des effets on
peut venir se marre un peu venir faire
de choses mais voilà je suis pas
aujourd'hui convaincus que ce mode là
soit vraiment pas dingue et je vais
d'ailleurs montré sur mon test première
partie de test vidéo sur le s 22 ultra
aller jeter un oeil si vous l'avez pas
vu je vous en parle et vous allez voir
pour pas également du mode vidéo
portrait et que bon voilà pourquoi pas
mais pas forcément recommandé et vous
pouviez moi d'avoir sur la caméra de
saïfi alors si c'est un petit peu sur
optimisé parce que j'ai les éclairages
donc ça sera tout de suite un peu mieux
avec quelques effets différents voyez
pas me faire ça si je veux avoir un côté
gritche et je veux venir marrer je peux
venir mettre également celui là avec un
point couleur donc moi je suis en
couleur et tout le reste est en noir et
blanc donc c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal fichu on voit que le détourage on
voit vraiment le détour au niveau des
doigts pour là aussi au niveau de mon
oreille la voyez mais bon voilà on peut
faire des trucs qu'on peut pousser
davantage celles à venir un peu plus
compliqué pour lui le côté grains de
cercle voyez si je le pousse à fond tout
de suite il va avoir beaucoup plus de
mal lorsque je vais venir bouger si je
veux que ce soit à peu près intéressant
il faut que je diminue mais même là ça
se voit donc le grand grand serbe part
donc avec grand cercle c'est pas ouf si
je le mets sur le flou normale et que je
n'ai pas trop fort je peux avoir quelque
chose mais bon voilà c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment le truc que je vais
ça se voit ça pompe c'est pas mal je
trouve sympa bah oui
il ya un autre point que je voulais voir
avec vous qui est vachement important
c'est la question de la performance
parce qu'ici on a vu arriver un nouveau
processeur du côté de chez samsung c'est
l'exil aux 2200 les egos de 1200 qui a
un partenariat avec amd au niveau du gpu
au niveau de la partie graphique elle
regarde et là je vous fais une petite
partie d'asphalté 9 alors bonne idée
reste peut-être pas le jeu le plus
compliqué le plus tordu au niveau
graphique mais pour autant je trouve que
dans l'ensemble ça fonctionne bien c'est
vrai que je ne vois pas de
ralentissement laissera processeur très
haut de gamme on est gravé sur du 4
nanomètres ici donc ça me paraît normal
d'avoir une expérience qui fonctionne
complètement et qui est totalement sûr
optimisé donc pas de problème là dessus
est ce que je vois tout de suite en
jouant comme ça à quelques jeux un vrai
bénéfice d'avoir ici le processeur en
partenariat avec amd je vous cache pas
que je vais pas tout de suite énormément
le bénéfice mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'expérience est là c'est fluide ça
fonctionne donc il n'y a rien qui me
permettrait de dire que ça ne soit pas
efficace d'autant plus que l'heure
tourne et on sort de là j'ai regardé et
j'ai fait un benchmark avec en tout et
avec en tout où j'arrive au score de
quasiment neuf cent mille huit cent
soixante
1824 c'est bien c'est extrêmement en or
alors c'est le score qui me sort
attention c'est qu'un match mc ça vaut
ce que ça vaut mais son ça vachement
bien alors si je regarde ce que leur un
cri d'antoura déchets vous montrer ça
regardait c'est le classement dans tout
pour android pour janvier 2022 alors on
voit qu'on a le mieux 12 pro qui est à
979 mille c'est à dire 100 milles de
plus que ce qu'on a ici alors il faut
savoir qu'ici on est sur le snapdragon 8
de première génération et apprendre à la
rade magic 6 le raid magic si ce qui est
moins performant parce que le raid magic
si ce qui est plus bas pourquoi parce
qu'ici on est sur le snapdragon 888 donc
là on a une vraie génération différence
ou du côté de chez qualcomm ce que nous
explique ses cent mille 2 cordes
différence niveau est qu'avec un score à
860000 je suis vraiment dans les clous
alors moi j'avais vu un match marqué ce
que j'étais parti à white avec qualcomm
on avait fait un match marqué j'avais un
test à plus d'un million donc on peut
faire encore mieux que ceux mis 12 pro
bien qu'on ait 12 giga de ram ici on
peut faire mieux on peut aller plus loin
en tout cas ce que je vois ici c'est que
860 milles c'est vachement bien et si je
regarde voyez sur le le benchmark dans
tout haut je vais chercher un smartphone
de cinq ans avec un processeur de
qualcomm est-ce que je vais me trouver
ici un exil au sein exynos ça c'est pas
de l'exil aux je crois pas voilà j'ai un
exil aux loyers est bien là j'étais à
739 millions dans tous les cas j'ai un
gain et ce qui est sûr c'est que j'aurai
un gain effectivement d'un point de vue
benchmark au niveau du score mais qu'en
plus de ça j'aurai un gain une
amélioration au niveau gaming alors
maintenant on étend pas moi-même un
gamer j'ai pas passer des heures des
heures et des heures à jouer comme un
dingue mais ce que je vois ici c'est que
ça fonctionne c'est fluide c'est réactif
ça marche bien vous fait tourner tous
les jeux de dupes les stores sont sans
aucun problème et ça c'est vachement
bien donc l'expérience globale en termes
de performances de gaming est tout pour
moi là-dessus samsung a aussi fait un
très joli travail comme on a du wifi 6,6
connect très rapidement sans aucun
problème on va venir gagner avec des
débits un peu plus rapide ok vous avez
un autre truc celle ultra wide band
alors ça c'est assez marrant c'est que
vous n'avez pas dû le travail de bandes
sur le samsung galaxy s 22 vous l'avez
uniquement sur le s bahn de plus c'est
une des différences qui pour moi
important parce que si vous avez acheté
ou si vous voulez acheter un smart tags
plus qui permettra de venir retrouver
vos objets que vous pouvez mettre sur
des clés comme être dans un bagage ou
être dans un sac vous venez vous preniez
votre smartphone et vous avez de la
réalité augmentée qui vous permettra de
venir retrouver vos objets extrêmement
rapidement c'est ça l'intérêt de l'ultra
wide band parce que le spartak plus on
peut venir se connecter en bluetooth et
il vous dira ok je suis bon coin mais si
vous voulez vraiment de la précision
ultra wide band il ya uniquement le f-22
plus qu'il a appartenu à cheval de plus
le f-22 ultra la vente de l'huile à part
ça c'est aussi un temps qui est
vachement intéressant bien évidemment
samsung paye google paye avec le nfc
certifié ip 68 c'est un grand minimum
est alors celui là il est dispo à partir
de jeudi j'ai de config 828 1059 euros
et 8 256 milles 109 euros donc s'il vous
intéresse vous pouvez y aller dès
maintenant et je vous le recommande une
fois de plus avec les bugs pro offert et
en plus de ça s'est un peu loupé un truc
est vachement intéressant au niveau de
leur offre de lancement est bien c'est
que si vous avez un ancien smartphone il
vous le reprennent et en plus il rajoute
100 euros pour vous permettre de le
toucher un peu moins cher et vous avez
des coloris unique sur le site de
samsung je vous invite à aller voir mais
le lien juste en bas dans la description
cliquez dessus allez jeter un oeil vous
verrez les couleurs uniques à sont
plutôt pas mal et moi j'ai un petit coup
de coeur pour le ciel voilà c'est tout
ce que j'avais à vous raconter
aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s 22 plus alors on reste très
proche du s 22 s 22 et es22 plus sont
quelques différences je vous le dis dans
ma précédente vidéo je vous invite à
venir la voir comme ça vous verrez
effectivement quelles sont ces
différences mais c'est un smartphone que
j'aime beaucoup et je vous le dis une
fois de plus ce côté extrêmement premium
me plaît énormément et je trouve
vraiment bon en termes de photos et en
terme de vidéo à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en banco mentalement vous
le trouvez ce samsung galaxy s 22 plus
il peut vous tentez oui non quoi comment
ici vous intéresse je me tous les liens
bien évidemment justement de la
description affiliation quand tu nous
tiens je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous et à très vite pour continuer à
parler de samsung et notamment du
samsung galaxy s 22 ultras qui est aussi
extrêmement extrêmement vous embrasse à
bientôt
[Musique]